so this is okay
this is a joint work with each household
um
and i'll be talking about uh yeah this
this uh interpolation of his transition
with two layers
uh networks and okay the focus is on
what is called the lazy regime
and and i'll explain what this is
uh about the talk so what are two layers
neural networks are this class of
functions i'll try to be as
self-contained as i can
are this kind of functions uh
so they are composition sums of uh
you know nonlinear function applied to
linear projection of the data
and you combine with these
qualifications al
okay so it's a parametric class of
function which is parameterized by this
weight al and these vectors
wl we want to use this data
this function to fit data so you know
throughout the
top most of the talk data will be iid
pairs
x i y i you have lowercase n
of them and they are id from some
distribution on
rd times r so x i
the vector x i is in rd
and and the label y i is a real number
okay and what we want to do we want to
figure out a function
f from rd to r as to minimize
or to make as small as possible the test
error
okay what is the test error is
you know the expected the mismatch
between f of x and y
you stop it you don't hear me anymore
let's see okay no i can't i can hear you
i don't know okay
all right okay let me know because
because i
modified my setup just before the talk
okay so the test error is the mismatch
between a new label
and f of the future vector
okay so it turns out that uh uh it is
often the case in
in modern neural networks that you know
gradient descent algorithms actually do
this
by finding an interpolating solution and
here
in this talk what i mean by
interpolating solution is a
is a function is a is a two-layer neural
network so it's a function in this
this class such that f x i is equal to y
i
for all data points okay so
you you you look at the data points and
the data that the the function is able
exactly to to fit the data so the
picture that you would have in mind is
that the x
is d here and the y i are there
and your function exactly passes through
all the data points
okay so mathematically what this means
is it means that you have a set of
lowercase sign equations and is my set
of data points
in a number of parameters while now the
parameters are the al
and the wl so in total you have capital
n
times d plus one parameters okay
so you have roughly and the parameters
and
lowercase and equations and the question
is can you solve this
you know you try to solve this problem
so there are a couple of you know a few
uh theoretical questions that is
interesting to ask
question number one uh for which triple
lowercase and uppercase and d does the
solution exist
this is the the so-called question of
network
capacity second you know can
can this solution be found in in
efficiently and in particular via
gradient descent
and third what is the test error so
you know once i i substitute this
interpolating solution
in this you know test error uh
will it be small or large okay
so the objective of this talk is try to
address this question
in a specific context okay before
going there perhaps it's good to pause a
second and ask you if the setting is
clear
okay please let me know because i cannot
see all of you
nodding or not okay so let me start by
uh
by mentioning uh
a little history about this topic
in particular history of the question of
network capacity
in the context of classification
okay
the constant of classification
this was uh you know the work started
you know quite a long ago so first paper
to mention is cover
1965 that basically solved the case
n equal one so only one neuron and then
the case of general
uh so okay let me mention there is an
obvious
lower bound you know need the number of
parameters
to be larger than the number of
equations
so the question is really whether you
can
you know this lower bound is tight or
not and cover
through that in the case n equal one and
baum in
1985 proved in the
this is the case for general n
okay so notice that the case of
classification is easier because in that
case what you're trying to
to do is really solve the set of linear
inequalities
of a set of inequalities right so
it's kind of easier that you know
to try to to solve this and and
so this is these two papers give
constructions of neural networks but not
algorithms okay this is
not really correct they really give an
algorithm but the algorithm is not
what you would do in practice and the
question was
for classification was the rabbit seated
recently by danieli
uh okay it has he has two paper 19 and
20
for in general
and from gradient descent okay so the
two papers are under slightly different
assumptions and conclusions but
okay broadly speaking he addresses this
question
the question is much less studied for
regression
so in this case we want really y i equal
f of x
i and uh okay there is
one main paper to mention there is a
recent paper by
you know concurrent paper by bubeck
okay is bubek has done limi clincher
i don't know the pronunciation 2020
and and what they they have is
in this paper they have two sets of
results two type of result
first they have a construction in a way
a little bit reminding the construction
of baum
for nd bigger than foreign
and the relu function the construction
is a little bit uh you know
artificial in particular they point out
that it leads to a large normal network
so probably not one that could gives a
good classification
generalization error and then they have
another result
for nd bigger than n log one over
epsilon
and always relu i think and
this achieves uh interpolation up to an
error x
epsilon
and and it has a smaller norm
but you know there is no no bound on the
on the generalization
no no uh interesting bond
okay okay so this is regarding the
history of this problem
and uh yeah what is small and large
what do those terms mean ah yeah good
good question perhaps some of the
authors of this paper other
in the audience
should i try to answer yeah
there is there is a natural norm
like notion of norm right which
is uh yeah you you just
take uh basically the sum
of l2 weights of the neurons
actually there is there is a paper by
you peter
by peter bartlett from i think like 20
years ago which
argues about this norm being a good
proxy for generalization
so this is i um i don't remember the
name of the norm
though um i think that's called
total weight in your paper peter
um it's just you mean the l1 norm of the
premise is like yeah basically yeah yeah
i mean depends how yeah it's just the l1
norm
of the sum of like weights of the
neurons times the
the norm of the vector so yeah you could
think about it as an
l just an l1 norm of the network
um and what we show
is that basically we give a construction
where the norm achieved is the optimal
one
right um
but the implication on generalization of
that norm for this specific regime are
you know unclear
okay so right we we
we addressed this thing this question in
in as i mentioned what's called the lazy
regime
or or also the neural tangent regime
and okay this was first introduced by
jakku gabriel and
okay there are some older papers but
this is really put it to
the four in 2018 and and what this means
is that
instead of the original class of
function i look at a simpler class of
function
the anti-class of function this is you
know depends on a set of weight
w and so this is defined as the set of
function
functions f x a that takes the form sum
over i
1 to n a i times x
times sigma prime of w i
times x so these brackets are scalar
product and here
this is parameterized by set of vectors
a
i in rb okay so
here w the weights w are fixed
so w is w1
wn so these are fixed and write the talk
they'll be
not normal but they will be uniform
on the unit sphere in the dimension okay
so you know so this is uh another class
of functions is parameterized by
n times the parameters
namely only all of these vectors
ai and the wi are fixed and they are not
fit to the data
the nice thing about this class of
functions of course that is linear
now a couple of remarks here there are
many things that can be said about this
model but remark number okay marks
remark number one is that
the the the neural tangent class
is a subset of the closure
of the neural network class with two n
neurons
okay and the way you see it so basically
the neural tangent models are a special
case of neural networks and the way you
see it is for instance this
one look at one over two epsilon
next
okay so look at this construction this
is a neural network with
2n neurons of course and you take the
limit
epsilon to 0
and this coincides exactly with f x a as
i brought above
right here the assumption is that uh
so converges for instance in l2
okay so so you know
with 2n neurons you can basically build
an
empty model and this is actually also
used in the
bubecketal paper and and a second remark
okay these are
be much bigger so you know
this means that to prove that there
exists a neural network that
interpolates
the data is sufficient to prove that
there exists a neural tangent
network that interpolates the data if
i'm i'm allowed to take limits and the
second remark is about
computability or or efficient
computation
and if i do gradient descent in
in
in in the space of neural network with
two end neurons with that initialization
with initialization of that type
this is well approximated by gradient
descent
in the neural tangent class
okay what's happening here
okay so this means that so for this
there is a lot of
references starting in again 2008
and i'll just mention do it all
but there is many more okay so all of
this
paper and okay i should mention also
she's i'm back
in particular shizabak show that if you
if you scale
a pro appropriately the initial
initialization and the gradient descent
you basically converge
gradient descent in the neural network
model converges to gradient descent
neural tangent class okay
so this is the general type of
thing that we'll be doing okay now i'm
puzzled because my
sorry i'm having some trouble with my
ipad
okay okay the setting
or the type of hypothesis that i look at
are the following the x i
will be
normal zero id
and then sigma will be weakly
differentiable
with the sigma prime of x
bounded by polynomial
and then uh okay the the
the dimension and the number of neuron
will be polynomially related
so yeah there exists an epsilon
positive such that say 0.01 such that
capital n is bigger than d to the
epsilon okay
and then i'll add some more hypothesis
as results are stated
okay so the question interpolation in
this setting is just the question of
solving a set of linear equation
and the linear equation are of the form
sum over uh l
1 1 a l
time max wl
times x i
okay so you want to solve this equation
in the al
it's convenient to define a piece of
notation so let me define this map
fee from rd
to r
to the nd okay this is the map that
takes a vector
x and spits out phi of x
oh what's happening
sorry i'm moving again trouble with my
ipad
this is really annoying i'm sorry i'm
trying to write and it doesn't
write you know it's kind of frustrating
sometimes reconnecting your pen can help
reconnecting my if you like reattach the
pen to the
to the ipad well the pen is not
attached to anything
sometimes the pen loses connection with
the ipad the bluetooth connection so
maybe that's the problem
the pen doesn't have bluetooth and or
the computer
no between the ipad and uh and your how
are they connected right
ah wow but uh yeah that's true
but uh okay let's try to see if i can go
on
hey
this is so annoying
but the pen shouldn't i mean this is
just uh
they're not writing even independently
um sometimes you want to check whether
the tip of the
hand is like tight
yeah perhaps the tip of the pen
okay you want to make sure that's tight
and tight okay um
okay so i managed to write it
except i made the mistake
okay so this is the map that takes a
vector x and spits out a vector of
length nd that has
uh you know one row of this equation in
it
okay and uh and so so this is
you know the system of linear equation
you can write it in terms of a matrix fv
that is the matrix that has rows v of x1
blah blah blah
field
xn
okay and and
you know so this is a matrix that is
n
by n d
and this set of linear equation is just
capital phi
times a equal y okay
so interpolation means that the set of
linear equation
has a solution okay and we know that
this has
a solution
exists for most
y and you know if exist for most is
exist for all y
what i'll try to change pen
why
if and only if uh the rank
of this matrix fee
is equal to n okay so this is the basic
question
one basic question that we want to
answer and
you know this is the first theorem that
tested
so this is again with echo we chose
zhong
and okay one way to state the theories
in terms of the kernel matrix that is
fifi transpose
okay so this is and then this is the
empirical kernel
is an n by n matrix let me define
another piece of
notation that characterizes so sigma is
only characterized through
the variance of sigma prime of g
this variance is taken with respect to g
normal zero one
okay and then okay we assume
there exists c zero positive
such that n
is less than c 0 d
and then
c1 uh finite
such that if nd
divided logan look d to the c1
is less than uh it's bigger
then then then
lambda mean of
k uh is bigger or equal than d
sigma minus some small
law in probability
okay so the theorem is basically telling
you that
uh not only okay you have to give me
some extra log factors
this log n log d to the c one but if you
give me this
extra log factor not only the the matrix
v is full
rank but i have a quantitative lower
bound
on the on the minimum singular value of
the kernel
uh and okay how good is this lower bound
turns out that okay if you if you if you
look
okay fair with time to talk a little bit
about the proof
it's pretty clear that lower bound is
tight
um and depends on sigma only
if on the variance of sigma prime of
course if sigma prime is
is a constant that is sigma is linear
then the problem is somehow degenerate
the real you know somehow strongest okay
we make this assumption about the
distribution of
the data but even within the model uh
the data
distribution model that we assume we
have to assume
capital n linear in d this is just
you know a weakness of the proof okay
you know
something like this should be true for
for you know polynomial
and polynomial indeed but i think this
regime is already interesting enough
okay so corollary is of course uh what
we wanted about
interpolation
uh
uh without probability for any y
so here y can be generic of course
uh there exists a in r
and d that parameterize the neural
tangent model
such that f and t x i
a is equal to y i
okay uh so there is interpolation and
since we are in the in the
kind of neural tangent regime can be
found by
by gradient descent if you know
okay so this is about uh you know the
first two questions
that is you know where the phase
transition is
and and
and whether you know such interpolators
can be found efficiently
uh there is a a third question that is
you know interesting from a
uh statistical point of view is the one
of generalization
or test error
in this case the two coincide and okay
we studied this in a specific setting
that is we assume a model for y
and more specifically we take a linear
model
so this is of course very simplistic
here epsilon i are independent random
variables with
and some variance
and okay so one note is is this very
restrictive this linear
model yes but okay the most general case
is not
much more general because if capital n
is of order d
as long as we keep to this regime a
model of this type in large dimension
can fit
okay i should have said from the
beginning but here we are always assume
yeah n and d going to infinity
can fit at most
quadratic functions
and can fit is in the approximation
sense namely if you
give me a third third-order polynomial
that has zero to projection or linear
function quadratic function you cannot
approximate
it to any non-trivial extent by a neural
tangent model okay so this
is a result that we obtained last year
with the
gorbani may mr cavitz
myself okay so okay
there is an interesting generalization
of what we did that is go to quadratic
function but beyond that test
as long as we keep the number of neurons
linear in the dimension large there is
not much to do
okay so this is this is uh the test
error and
okay here i should have said so
how do we fit this model for for for
studying the tester we use rage
regression
so we have to fit these capital nd
parameters
and we do this by minimizing
this cost function
with the average penalty
okay so this is really we can also
rewrite using
the notation that i brought here this is
a
quadratic cost in the a
a plus a rich penalty okay so these are
all l2 norms
and okay and we are interested in
in studying the the test error
at value lambda so this will be the
expectation
with respect to the new data
of
the true
minus f of
okay now why are we interested in reach
regression
of old methods
first of all because it's it's it's very
convenient mathematically and second
there is a motivation for it is that
if i do uh in a linear model
so in a linearly parameterized model if
i
run gradient descent starting at zero
initialization gradient descent
converges
to the mean l to norm solution
so two a hat of lambda equals zero plus
see okay so if you have a you know
least squares and you solve list squares
in an over parameterized model
uh using gradient descent initially
initializing at zero
it will converge to the minimum to
normal solution
so in so far the you know neural tangent
model is
accurate so you start with this
initialization with
one over epsilon in front of the
coefficients
um now the mean uh
l to normal solution of the ridgeless
limits of
rich regression will will capture the
generalization error of
uh gradient descent so
i think that the most informative way to
state our result about the
generalization is as an equivalence or
approximately equivalence
and equivalences with a simple model
and the simple model is just vanilla
linear
rich regression so what is vanilla rich
regression
is what you would do if you didn't know
anything about
neural networks
and you fit just a linear model in the
dimensions
with regularization parameter gamma
okay and of course i can i can define
once i do this
uh x is just the n by d matrix
with the row x size
and i can define of course the the risk
of linear rich regression let's call it
gamma this is
okay now this is of course an object
that in this model is
is quite easy to to study in particular
you can compute its asymptotics
okay using random metrics theory
using just very really simple
on the metrics theory okay
okay uh so in particular there is a
paper that
we wrote with trevor hesti
and a bunch of other people in which you
know we do all sorts of these
calculations
okay so what is the theorem here
well same assumption
as in the first first theorem so in
particular
always n c zero d for some
big constant c and
gaussian data and linear truth under
this assumption we have that
the risk of the neural tangent model at
regularization lambda
is equal to the risk of the linear model
at a new regularization that i'll call
gamma effective
that depends on lambda and sigma the
activation function
plus an error
uh that is of order and
log d to the c
okay so here we're not very careful in
tracking the
the log factors but okay
and here the effective regularization
is is what is lambda
plus b of sigma
divided by e of sigma prime
where expectation here is always with
respect to the gaussian measure
okay so this is the theorem you get as
good as realization as
as generalization as if you did the just
uh linear regression uh the interesting
fact is that you don't know that things
are linear to start with so
in a sense you know you're more adaptive
a couple of remarks here
there is this interesting change in
regularization
in particular even if lambda is equal to
zero so you you look at the min norm
interpolator
in the neural tangent model the
effective regularization
is strictly positive okay
so this implies uh the fact that gamma
lambda equals zero uh
can be optimal
okay namely you know if you take the
so one big puzzle here i tried to i
didn't go too much into the statistical
or machine learning
aspects of this problem focus the around
the math aspects but one
very interesting type of phenomenon that
was
studied by many people you know and
is that you get good generalization net
error with these networks even if the
training error is
zero so lambda equals zero means
training
error zero so interpolation and this can
be the optimal regularization
uh despite the fact that you are
interpolating the data and in this model
is seen very clearly because
the effective regularization in the
linear model is strictly positive
so you can easily construct models
at high snr snr
here is basically the norm of beta0
over the variance of the noise
you can easily build model in which
the optimal regularization for ridge
regression is small
in particular is smaller than v
of sigma divided by
of sigma prime square
and in this case uh
of in this case the optimal
lambda will be zero okay
and the underlying mechanism has been
studied before for instance liang
rocklin peter myself etc but okay here
we see it directly in the
model related to neural networks and the
underlying mechanism
is of course the kernel matrix as
this piece that is proportional to v
sigma times the identity plus other
stuff
and this v sigma on the diagonal from
from our first year and this v sigma on
the diagonal
acts as a regularizer um
second thing you might ask about the
optimality about of our theorem
uh we don't think it's optimal we
suspect it can be
improved but okay one good thing is that
the other term
we don't think that the error term is
optimal but is negligible
if uh
what n over d is much smaller than
n to the one third modulo log factors
and this is
basically obtained by balancing this by
comparing these two terms
okay the error of linear regression of
order
uh lowercase and over lowercase d and
then you balance it with the other term
and you get
this kind of scaling if i'm not correct
so this covers at least
an interesting ring okay so perhaps i'll
pause one minute
and then i'll go to describe some proof
ideas
um andrea can ask a question
um gamma opt is strictly smaller than b
sigma over the
this expectation of derivative squared
um
uh you you may have a a ridge
an optimal ridge penalty that's negative
yeah yeah
so so i'm not saying that there is a
simpler model in which you can see all
of this and that
was
okay now i mean there is a
a a simpler model for this that is you
just do
uh you know linear regression in which
you add noise to the
to the covariates in that case also you
can have an optimal
uh this was started first by
some other people that know a very
forgotten name
uh so but yeah you can have in that
model an optimal penalty that is
negative
and i think in this model as well
yes okay now i don't know if it's
something that i would advise
to practitioners but to do but
you know in these models you can do
these strange things
okay um
a few words about the proofs
okay the the cracks really you know as i
try to mention is try to control
the the kernel matrix
okay so this is an n you know
matrix indexed by the data points whose
entry k
j is 1 over nd
if you remember my definition of phi sum
over l
1 to n sigma
x i x j
times sigma prime
of wl x i
times sigma prime of wl
x j
okay so
it's a bit of a tricky matrix if it was
just the first piece
it would be this short metric so if
sigma prime is
a constant if the activation is linear
this is just a v short matrix
uh but okay remind
that the x i are random in my model
but uh okay here there is this part that
makes it if there was no first part then
would be
if there was no first term then there
would be a
kernel in a product a random matrix but
is
is a bit more complicated than that and
the challenge really one
one challenge is
okay remember that we want to prove that
this is
basically bigger than this v of sigma
times i
and and so you know you try one might
want to try some concentration
bounds but it's not true
that if you look at k minus
you know some any v any constant v times
i
this is much smaller than v okay
so it's not concentration this is lower
bounded by a constant times the identity
but is not
because it's very close to a constant
times the identity
okay so one is to do a little bit more
work and identify
some large eigenvectors or potentially
large eigenvalue
and to do this what we do is that we
decompose
first of all we decompose the activation
function
as sigma prime of x equal okay we call
it
psi plus phi of x
where where phi this is orthogonal
decomposition
so this is zero and the expectation is
respect to g normal zero one
okay and accordingly you can decompose
the matrix
as psi
plus phi phi okay
and and these are you know for instance
v c i
l alpha so these are obtained by
substituting sigma prime to their
components this is v
wl x i
okay okay so this is the first
piece of of uh of the decomposition and
then the second
piece of the composition is that we
construct this projector
so this is an nd by nd projector
where each of the pi which the pl
is is what is wl wl transpose
and okay of course p orthogonal
is identity minus p
okay so with this in enhanced now we
write the
kernel as
first decomposing the part along p
and orthogonal to p and then we
decompose
fee
into the low degree part and the high
degree part
this is p orthogonal p orthogonal
and okay now all of this looks
mysterious but hopefully in a minute it
will be
kind of
clearer while we are doing this
and then we have the last part
okay so
now what is nice about this
decomposition
is that uh
this part here is okay slow rank
because p is a project of rank capital n
and is obviously pst okay we want to
lower bound
k and so that's good
and and now this part
is a low degree part
okay so let me call it l
and this is really the most
interesting part this is the high degree
part let me call it k bar
okay and what we prove is two two things
uh
l so we have only to deal with l and k
we prove that l is small in the sense
that
it will slower bounded by a small
constant
possibly negative times the identity and
and now k concentrate
k bar concentrate around this v
sigma
uh
so this now should clarify why why
uh i don't expect you know
this bound is tight in the sense that
okay we have this low ranked part
this will not change the minimum
singular value
and this low degree part will not be
will not
raise this minimum similar value either
okay and okay last five
minutes just one word about uh you know
these two bounds okay actually only the
the last bound how do we prove the last
bound and
why reducing to k bar simplifies uh life
where we prove uh
two by by matrix concentration
inequality in particular by friedman
metrics freedman inequality
for matrix martingale
so this is due to oliveira drop
drop oliveira
right so it's a matrix concentration
equality for for matrix valued
martingales and and uh
okay so what is the martingale uh okay
what is
what why is this uh now this matrix is
easy to deal with
let me call let me look at just the out
of diagonal terms
and now should be clear why i impose
this constraint
this this projector
w l x i project all w
l x j
times sigma prime
wl x i times sigma prime of w
l x j
and okay what is nice very nice about
now
here what i did this is just the matrix
k bar in which i
i eliminated the diagonal so i put this
indicator here the diagonal can be
treated separately
what is very nice here is that now
this piece is independent of this piece
right
because x is gaussian and here i'm
projecting orthogonal
to the gaussian so now these two pieces
are zero
are are independent so this and oh i
should have
changed now this has zero mean
remember that i i i just removed the
zero
the the constant part psi i removed the
from the activation the constant
part all right so phi is zero mean this
b zero mean they are uncorrelated so
there is a lot of structure that you can
exploit and the the way we construct the
martingale is
we construct the filtration that is
uh we condition on all the w
and on the first m
of the uh data points
okay and then we call
okay k hat m just
the expectation of k hat
given fm
okay and what is nice about this matrix
is that
the con this k hat m
is just zero uh
it's a very simple structure is
basically k
hat i j in the top
corner up to 1 3 m
and 0 elsewhere
so it's very easy to do
with this thing and exploiting the
independence
and uh and okay
is not completely trivial but yeah
you know with a bit of of care one can
get this
this concentration bound that i wrote
here
and and again the the generalization
bound once you have the
the bound on the on the kernel matrix is
basically
about you know writing explicitly the
the rich regression in terms of p
and k and then approximating each matrix
by
uh okay this should be times identity
by by you know using this theorem
okay i think that's that's all for for
the talk
and yeah okay perhaps i couldn't could
mention that there is
uh you know a large number of open
problems for instance here we use a very
specific data distribution
that is x are normal can we generalize
it
beyond that i have no idea
okay that's all i think thank you
thank you so much uh are there questions
someone typed a question into the chat
but you can just unmute yourself to ask
i was wondering that since the phi
matrix
has um uh independent rows
um so uh if is there like a regime of
um in the end length
expects that it will behave matrix
whose um with independent rows
um whose covariance is every row matches
the covariance of
the right the rows of the fire matrix ah
yeah i think so
i think so um
yeah i even thought i even brought down
the model
uh um so the question is
uh yeah so
if you look at a simpler model that is
somewhat simpler model that is there is
a simpler model that is the random
future models in that case
the matrix phi is replaced by
let's call it phi r f
that is uh now uh
n by n matrix whose entries are
x i sigma of x i dot w wl
okay in this case it was
you know shown for this uh
for this ridge regression problem and
conjunction more
more more generally that this matrix
fire arrives at least in the
proportional regime in which capital n
is proportional to lower case and
is basically equivalent for many
purposes to a
gaussian random matrix with the right
covariance structure
and yeah i expect the same to be
true here for this model probably one is
to take
and the proportional okay i think there
is some work
in that in that direction by
pennington and other but okay i i think
it's true also in this regime
it's a more complicated random metrics
uh
model because the covariance has a more
complicated structure
but yeah i think it's true
[Music]
but yeah it's it's probably difficult to
prove
one part of the talk you mentioned that
uh
once you have sigma even if lambda is
zero it
the non-linearity sort of gives you a
regularization
right uh so is that
[Music]
like so it's generically true for every
non-linear function
uh as in as in
other choices of sigma that give you the
reverse of regularization like that
it could make the regularization worse
well
if you if you look at this uh
okay let's see where did i write the
theorem
if you look at this theorem uh you know
really
what's crucial here is uh i mean what
is this implicit regularization is
basically this b
of sigma term and this is the variance
of sigma prime
right so this is always
positive um basically one way to think
about it i mean this you see it very
easily in in kernel methods in either so
this you can think of a
a complicated kernel method in the sense
that the kernel itself is
is random right but if you look at the
simpler setting that
is somewhat simpler setting so this was
studied for instance by younger rattling
and before them by el carui
and by us so
the setting in which the matrix
k i j is just a deterministic function
of x i
dot x j then what happens is that
uh in that case the situation is
is relatively simpler that uh
you know for two vectors x i x j and i
dimensions so the right scaling is
killing this
by square root of d or
no by d actually
and in high dimension the scalar product
for two distinct vectors is of order one
over square root of d so you can
linearize the function
but if the two vector for i equal to j
this is k of zero so k of one
so k i i is equal to the function k
at one while k i
j is basically k 0
plus k prime 0 over d times x
i transpose x j right so you see that
you have an extra term on the diagonal
that comes because of this
so you see the non-linearity in the
terminal only when the two points
coincide
this is true this argument is true for
uh again n over 30.
if you look at n that scales polynomial
indeed then you
have to look at higher so you see you
see clearly that
this has always to be non-negative right
because
the diagonal of a kernel is non-negative
right so so so here you see it
very clearly and this generalized to
polynomial scalings
if you here you do a higher terms in the
expansion
in the you know you can approximate this
by adding
terms in in the taylor expansion uh
and basically we are we are we are
showing the same phenomenon in a
you know somewhat more complicated model
well the kernel is not
is not deterministic because depends on
the
depends on these w's okay in our case
andrea so you're saying that the
implicit regularization comes from that
diagonal
the extra diagonal that's what you're
saying it takes
yeah it comes from the diagonal and then
yeah
so regarding the generalization
uh if instead of uh considering
the linear model you consider functions
that only depend on one direction
but are not linear like
some nice function
on the scatter product with some vector
do you believe that
you know basically the same will hold
true
like no no no the situation
the things will be would be different
right so okay so the question
i don't know who is asking the question
uh what happens if
your function is a okay people call it
in statistics a rich function
so it's g of some w zero transpose times
x right so now this neural tangent model
uh
will not work well right in particular
even
if you have infinitely many data you
will not approximate
well this thing right so this is the
theorem that i mean quickly mentioned
before
if i take hand that is less than in fact
less than
n to the 2
d to the 2 minus
epsilon and you take a function like
this
in over f in the neural tangent class
of f 0 minus f
two this is equal to
uh the projection basically of
this function f zero onto polynomial of
degree bigger than
two okay
basically you you cannot even if you
have infinitely many data you will not
uh yeah but well but if it's a nice if
g is a nice function like i don't know
maybe absolute value like
yeah same tool right or or maybe
you know supported once more free like
assume almost anything you want about it
just
you know i can you allow me to assume
if you allowed me to assume that g is
quadratic so this theorem
right this is not polynomial though not
polynomial
like that so this theorem applies to any
nf 0
and f0 and l2 and it's a an equal plus
small order term
right so
this theorem tells you that uh
you know you can take g as nice so this
is true within
the neural tangent model so this means
that if i want to study
generalization for this true function
i have or more general types of function
i have to go
beyond the neural tangent model
okay so i cannot work in this lazy
regime
i'm not saying that you know neural
networks will not generalize
well i'm just saying that the machinery
that i'm giving you here
will not work
right does that make sense
yeah it's in the i guess in the neural
tangent regime it's uh
pretty dead in that sense
also length asked the the n
capital n here should be lowercase n no
this should be capital n
this is just an approximation question
uh know there is no model in the neural
tangent class that approximates well
a function of this type if
g is not a quadratic function
and in particular in general any
function in l2 if it's not
a quadratic function
and of course i have a question yeah
uh you showed your theorem was lambda
min of
k greater than equal to v so is the v
like even the its type like the constant
even correct there
yeah if i had it's like really the
population if i had
infinite uh width
capital and it would also be v right
if i had infinite like the population
jacobian a population
kernel is the lower eigenvalue also v
is the population where we can uh
like if big n were infinite was the is a
lower eigenvalue also
yeah um i think i
knew this uh yeah
yeah i think so it is okay cool uh
i mean it's related to the fact that uh
here the limiting factor
is lowercase n
yeah i mean this we are looking at
lowercase and by lowercase and matrix
right
i think so
questions
okay if not then thanks andreas so much
for the seminar
thanks to you guys nice to see all of
you
thanks